One of the challenges we have with
wireless networks is that they are in
the air around us and anyone can tap in
to that air to listen in on our network
communication. For that reason, we need
to engineer our wireless networks to
allow the appropriate users access to
the network and prevent access from
anyone unauthorized. This generally
means we need to provide some type of
authentication before someone can use
the wireless network. This might be a
username, a password, or some other
factor of authentication. But of course,
if someone is listening into the
network, they'll be able to see all of
the traffic going back and forth, even
if they are not authenticated to the
network. For that reason, we also need
to enable encryption on everything that
goes over the air. And with most
wireless technologies, we also need some
way to confirm that the information that
we've received has not been modified
somehow along the way. Our wireless
technologies include an additional piece
of information known as a message
integrity check or MIC. And this allows
us to confirm that the information we've
received really is the information that
was
sent. If you've ever worked with a
wireless protocol analyzer, you know,
you simply turn it on and you can
immediately start gathering information
going across the air. For that reason,
we need to be sure that as much
information as possible is encrypted
over that very open airway. One way to
do this on a traditional 802.11 wireless
network is to use an encryption protocol
such as WPA2 or
WPA3. If we go back to 2002, a big shift
took place in the encryption of data on
wireless networks. We transitioned from
one of the original encryption types
which was web that stands for wired
equivalent privacy and we transitioned
to a new style of encryption known as
WPA. WPA stands for Wi-Fi protected
access. We found significant
cryptographic vulnerabilities with WE
and that drove us towards this
transition to WPA. But this first
implementation of WPA was designed to be
a stop gap. It was designed to prevent
any of the cryptographic problems we had
with WE, but we knew we needed something
longer term to be able to implement in
the future. One of the technologies
associated with this WPA stop gap was
that it encrypted using a technology
known as TKIP. This TKIP encryption ran
on the existing access point hardware,
which means that we could still provide
security over these wireless networks
without having to replace any of our
physical access points. That transition
period where we were using WPA for our
encryption technology didn't last very
long. In 2004, we introduced WPA2.
That's Wi-Fi protected access version 2.
This was the update to WPA. And the idea
was that we'd be able to use WPA2 for an
extended period of time. WPA2 used a
stronger type of encryption known as
AES. That's the advanced encryption
standard. This was a stronger encryption
method than the TKIP we were using with
WPA. But in many cases, it required
additional processing power, which means
we needed to replace access points if we
wanted to enable WPA2 encryption. This
change happened relatively quickly, and
most organizations were glad to swap out
their access points if it meant that
they would have better encryption over
their wireless networks. WPA2 has
continued to provide strong encryption
for our wireless networks, and you'll
still see many wireless networks running
WPA2 as the encryption
standard. As time went on, we continued
to improve these standards for our
wireless networks, and WPA3 was
introduced in 2018. This is Wi-Fi
protected access version 3. There were a
number of new features and capabilities
introduced with WPA3. One of them was
that the strength of the AES encryption
used on the wireless network was
increased to be more secure in WPA3.
WPA3 also increased security for an
initial key exchange that occurs when
somebody first connects to the wireless
network. WPA3 also included a new
feature to provide encryption on open
networks. So if you go to a coffee shop
that has an open wireless network, WPA3
can automatically create encryption keys
so that even though the network is open,
everything going across the airways are
still
secure. If you look at the configuration
of the wireless settings on your access
point, you may see a number of different
configuration options. One of them is an
open system. This is one that has no
password set and anyone can connect to
that wireless network. This might be the
configuration you would find in a coffee
shop or a hotel wireless network. If
you're setting up an access point for
personal use, especially at home, you're
probably configuring it with WPA2 or
WPA3 encryption. And for either of
those, you're probably assigning a
password or passphrase to help protect
that network. If anybody visits you, you
simply provide them with that password
and they're able to connect to your
wireless network. We refer to this
password as a pre-shared key. That's a
key that you would provide to anyone who
needs to connect to this wireless
network and everybody on the wireless
network is using the same key. In a
business, however, you don't want to
have everyone using the same key to
connect to the wireless network. Every
individual should have their own log on
to the wireless connection. If you were
to look at your access point, there's
probably a configuration to configure
WPA2 or WPA3 in an enterprise mode. You
might see this also listed as an
802.1x mode. This is an authentication
mode that requires someone to log in
with their username and password and
your access point uses a centralized
authentication database to be able to
confirm that this user is authenticating
correctly to this wireless network. This
means that every person in your
organization has a different login to
the wireless network. And if they leave
the organization, we can simply disable
their account and they no longer have
access to the wireless network.